-Hey, I'm Alessia Cara,
and this is "Three Scoops."
One of my secret talents --
I wouldn't --
I don't know
if it's, like, a talent,
but I, like, really love
to do a British accent
or an Australian one.
I'm like...
It's hard to transition. Um...
[Australian accent] Or I like
to do an Australian accent.
It's not as good.
[Normal voice] I'm still trying
to perfect my Owen Wilson.
I'm trying to get there.
I'm trying to just
perfect the, like...
[as Wilson] Wow.
[Normal voice]
That's all I've got for now.
One thing that people
tend to love,
and especially singers
that I cannot stand is tea.
And I know that
it doesn't work in my favor
'cause if I loved it,
then I should be drinking it
every day 'cause it's so good
for your voice.
It's healthy for you.
I just hate it. All kinds.
I'm not a fan.
So that doesn't really
come in handy
when I'm hoarse like today.
My dream collaboration?
I mean, so many people.
I would love to work with
Anderson .Paak
or Chris Martin, um, or --
Who else?
I mean, well, Amy Winehouse.
Obviously, she passed away,
but I would've loved
to work with her.
I don't know
if she was a fan of mine.
Thank you, guys, so much.
I'm Alessia Cara, and this
has been "Three Scoops."